when we hear natural it kind of sounds
like someone wanders through a forest
and picks leaves off trees and mashes
them to make your product it just sounds
more sustainable but that is pretty far
from reality there are lots of natural
ingredients that have huge environmental
costs to produce and skin care it's
usually wild harvested licorice that's
used because it has a high concentration
of the Active Components while the
licorice has been uncontrollably over
harvested to the point that there is now
more licorice being sold in the market
than there is being produced licorice
helps soils with sand management and
therefore over exploitation of wild
licorice in the Sandy regions it
typically grows directly contributes to
desertification